it's the drug-trafficking you don't hear
about more than 75 billion dollars worth
of fake pharmaceuticals are sold
globally each year inside these filthy
makeshift labs boric acid lead paint
often sheetrock just some of the toxic
ingredients found in counterfeit pills
that are sold online to customers around
the world it's a problem so big pharma
companies like Pfizer are now policing
it themselves at their counterfeit lab
scientists are doing the legwork the
evidence they gather here will then be
used to prosecute the purse for Pfizer
it's a winning formula their incentive
to protect the brand which is tainted by
more than 65 different fake Pfizer
products on the blackboard and today
they're training me to spot the real
deal and how can you tell just by
looking at it wow that's hard to tell
that's pretty similar to me inside we
find everything fake chapstick to
celebrate but the king of counterfeits
viagra there's nothing that inherently
looks fake about it can you tell which
is real here's how it works
step one document the sample step two
the physical exam as you tip the blister
the logo colors shifts from blue to
purple step 3
chemical analysis so here the for real
virus this is fundamentally different
step 4
file the report the brief is then handed
over to Bryan Donnelly after 21 years at
the FBI he's working for Pfizer we
probably average about one conviction
per week these are cases that we bring
to law enforcement or law enforcement
does on their own based upon training
that we do it's very important for us to
have patients recognize that when they
get a fine as a product and they see the
Pfizer name that they know that it's our
product we've gone through all of the
regulatory process to make it safe and
effective despite their work the black
market for fake drugs is growing
annually at a twenty percent cliff
and at that rate it's no wonder police
need outside help to keep up